Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was machen wir?
Wir gratulieren erst mal, hast du vorgeschlagen.
Ja, wir gratulieren, stellt euch lustige Musik vor. Wir haben natürlich kein Budget für feierliche Musik, aber der Tagesspiegel berichtet. Insgesamt gibt es demnach derzeit 249 Milliardäre in Deutschland, 23 mehr als im vergangenen Jahr. Also Krise.
Welche Krise?
Und so viele wie noch nie, seit das Magazin 2001 mit der Liste begonnen hatte. Ich möchte darauf hinweisen, in dieser Liste fehlt natürlich wieder diese eine Familie, die Julia Friedrichs auf Platz 1 und so weiter. In der Ansicht gratulation allen Beteiligten, weil die Unbeteiligten sehen ja außen vor.
Ja. Wengleich wir heute diskutieren werden im Salon, ob die Superreichen wirklich das Problem sind. Also ich will diese Frage noch einmal stellen. Ich habe mich erinnert an den Auftritt von Adam Toos bei Tilo damals. Und Tilo fragte dann ja, wie werden wir die los und was können wir machen? Und dann sagt er auch, ja, Verbote sind wichtig, dass die nicht mit Privatschritt rumfliegen. Aber Toos sagt, aber ist das unser größtes Problem? Haben wir nicht andere Probleme? Und jetzt haben wir dieses Buch gelesen von Philippa Siegel Klöckner. Und ich finde, es ist ein guter Zeitpunkt, um diese Frage noch mal zu stellen. Haben wir nicht noch andere Probleme? Oder heißt das größere Problem nicht Christian Lindner? Und hieß es nicht, Horst Seehofer, der taucht nämlich auch wieder in diesem Buch auf, auch wieder unglaublich eigentlich, was dieser Mann angerichtet hat.
Das Kapitel dazu heißt eine schlechte Idee, eine gefährliche Idee, die niemand hatte oder so. Und man denkt sich so, ach, ist bestimmt eine coole Pointe, weil niemand, doch Horst Seehofer. Ja. Aber ich habe auch den Clip von Adam Toos nochmal gesehen. Matthias hat ihn ja geteilt und Matthias macht sowas ja mit Hintergedanken. Also Matthias, wir haben dich geschaut. Ich bin ja sehr froh, dass wir zuletzt nicht nur gute Bücher gelesen haben, sondern dass wir hinter diesen Büchern auch immer institutionen sehen. Hier zum Beispiel Dezernat Zukunft oder die Finanzwende oder sanktionsfrei oder was auch immer. Wir können also sagen, es kümmern sich Leute um die relevanten Fragen. Also wie bekommt jemand noch mal eine Hilfe, obwohl das sanktionsregime des Bürgergeldempfängers schon wieder zugeschlagen hat oder was auch immer. Nur wir als publizistische Kraft kämpfen hier gegen Milliardäre. Darauf verpflichte ich dich. Nachher werde ich von dir ein Eid abnehmen. Aus dieser Nummer kommen wir nicht wieder raus.
Ja, ja. Okay. Ich will diesen Kampf auch nicht aufgeben. Ich will den Kampf Milliardäre abschaffen auf keinen Fall aufgeben. Aber wir werden heute eine Fokusverschiebung vornehmen und werden einige Akteure beleuchten, von denen man schon ahnte, dass sie nichts Gutes im Schilde führen. Aber es ist eigentlich noch alles viel schlimmer, da sehr viel Willkürherrschaft, viel Machtgetriebenes da eine Rolle spielt. Es ist ein erschreckendes, sehr erhellendes Buch. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, sprechen wir mal noch weiter über das Gute Geld, nämlich in Bezug auf Kultur. Wir hören jetzt mal den Anfang der Kulturzeit vom vergangenen Dienstag.
Ich freue mich, dass Sie Kulturzeit gucken. Aber stellen Sie sich mal vor, dass allein das oder ein Kulturzeit-Like in den sozialen Medien für Sie gefährlich werden könnte. Und das Recht für unser Team hier im studio und in den redaktionen. Denn so läuft es in Russland. Die Verbreitung von unabhängigen Berichten, sei es über Satellit oder YouTube, wird von der russischen Regierung blockiert. Selbst die Zuschauer haben Angst vor repression. Aber die Journalistinnen und Journalisten haben Orte gefunden, von denen aus sie senden können. Aus dem Untergrund. Roman Schell.
Irgendwo in Amsterdam. Ein geheimes fernsehstudio des russischen Senders TV Raine. Die Kreml-kritischen Journalistinnen im Exil haben Angst vor Giftanschlägen. Niemand vom technischen Personal darf gefilmt werden.
Inhaltlich soll uns das jetzt erst mal gar nicht interessieren. Wir stellen fest, es ist eine typische kulturzeitanmoderation und dann beginnt ein typischer Kulturzeitbeitrag. Sehr häufig geht es ja um Journalisten in aller Welt, wie sie ihre Arbeit machen können oder nicht. Hier jetzt in Bezug auf die Zensur in Russland. Dann aber kommt der nächste Beitrag, nachdem über diese Exilrussen, die journalistisch tätig sind, berichtet wurde. Dieser handelt jetzt davon, dass Kulturzeit möglicherweise bald am Ende ist, dass Dreisatz abgeschafft werden soll. Oder wie es dann höflich klingt in dem Vorschlag, der jetzt den Ministerpräsidenten vorgelegt wird, dass man Dreisatz mit Arte zusammenführt, was ja am Ende bedeutet, aus zwei Sendern wird einer und damit wird einer gestrichen. Da gibt es ja keine Zusammenführung.
Ich würde sagen, die Mathematik ist hier, aus einem halben Sender wird ein Viertel.
Richtig, ja. Denn es ist ja ohnehin schon so, dass Dreisatz gar nicht viele eigene produktionen macht. Es gibt Kulturzeit, es gibt Skobel, es gibt Übertragung aus Theater und Oper, aber es gibt ja nicht am ganzen Tag über eigene Sendung, sondern da wird ja sehr viel zugekauft und vieles wird auch so versendet, möchte ich sagen.
Wir sind ja dem Betrug eh schon auf die Schliche gekommen. Kulturzeit ist ja eine Sendung, die ich hab's ja mit Danny häufiger im Fernsehpodcast geschaut, wo wir uns dann nur die Kulturzeit, sagen wir mal, das letzten Monats angeschaut haben. Und wenn man aber gleichzeitig Heuteschanal und Tagesthemen schaut und im Heuteschanal kommt eben auch ab und zu am Ende so ein kulturelles Stück, dann ist das einfach eine Zweitverwertung. Also ist nicht mal so, dass die Kulturzeit Sachen produziert, die dann auch im Heuteschanal laufen, sondern die heuteschanal-redaktion macht etwas, was dann auch in der Kulturzeit ausgelagert wird, was ja schon mal zeigt, nicht wo die Engagements und Interessen liegen, sondern wo das Budget liegt.
Ja, Titel, Thesen, Temperamente greift ja auch Beiträge auf oder umgekehrt. Man weiß dann nie, wer da jetzt von wem irgendeinen Beitrag kauft. Jedenfalls ist es nicht so, dass alles original produziert wird. Und ich will jetzt hier auch nicht eine große Verteidigung der Kulturzeit anstimmen, da ich mit der Sendung auch seit langer Zeit hadere. Vielleicht kann ich dazu gleich noch mal was sagen. Aber wir hören uns jetzt...
Ja, aber eben, wir wollen jetzt ausdrücklich sagen, weil die so ein Schleichen den Tod stirbt. Von außen verordnet.
Und sie auch nicht mehr diesen Mut hat, wie früher, Dinge zu machen, die wichtig sind. Dann sage ich das einfach, es gab einfach früher viel mehr Interviews mit Leuten, die den Konsens gestört haben. Während man jetzt eher so ein Fernsehen macht, bei dem man sich immer absichert, ob Claudia Roth damit auch zufrieden ist. Und das ist aber nicht erst seit Claudia Roth im Amt ist, sondern ich würde sagen, das ist ein Niedergang, diese Anpassung, diese Konformität, die man seit zehn Jahren mindestens bei der Kulturzeit beobachten kann. Ich erinnere mich an meine Studententage als beispielsweise dort einmal die Woche ein Film vorgestellt wurde und zwar ein Klassiker. Und es war ein wunderbarer Sprecher, ich weiß gerade seinen Namen nicht, der sehr persönlich über diese Filme sprach und das Besondere hervorhob. Wahrscheinlich hat irgendein funktionär mal gesagt, naja, da schalten immer ein paar Leute weg, dann lassen wir das. Man hat sehr viel mehr über Literatur früher dort gesprochen, hat literarische Debatten aufgegriffen. Es ist sehr häufig bei Kulturzeit nur noch so eine Fortsetzung des Heute-Journals. Also eigentlich kann man sich im Fernsehen so vorstellen, wir haben heute-Journal und Tagesschau und dann gibt es die kulturelle Verarbeitung dessen, was wir da schon gesehen haben und auch derselbe Standpunkt wird eingenommen. Und wer es dann nochmal lustig braucht, kriegt es nochmal in der, wie heißt das, heute-Show oder wie heißt die andere Sendung, serviert. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich das, was Kunst ausmachen könnte, nämlich genau diesen Konsens zu stören und eine völlig andere Stimme reinzubringen, immer seltener. Und das war dann gerade auch z.B. im Zuge von Corona zu sehen. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, auch an den Fernsehpodcast, dass dann nur nochmal zugeschaltet war Ulrich Mattes, der sagte, wie schlimm die Querdenker sind. Ja, das habe ich aber schon woanders zehnmal gehört. Das mag ja auch stimmen. Nur ich würde jetzt vielleicht von der Kunst doch etwas anderes erwarten, als nur nochmal diesen Diskurs zu wiederholen. Ähnliches dann auch im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine. Ich brauche nicht jeden Abend drei Künstler, die nochmal Slava Ukraini in die Kamera rufen.
Es sind so düstere Zeiten, dass wir es gerade jetzt diese Woche wie folgt sagen müssen. Hotel Matze, also ein völliger Podcast für Leute, die auf dem Trip sind, alles zu psychologisieren, hatte jetzt Jonathan Mese und Harbe Kerkeling zu Gast. Was bedeutet, dass wir zum einen von Jonathan Mese nochmal erklärt bekommen, was eigentlich Sache ist, und zwar nicht der Kunst, sondern der Welt. Und sie sollte alle Kunst sein, damit man sich nicht immer in die Angelegenheiten des anderen einmischt und so weiter und so fort. Also man kann sich das stundenlang anhören und es ist einfach ein Spektakel. Und eben Harbe Kerkeling, der sagt, ja Showbusiness war für mich irgendwann vorbei, weil ich nach 30 Jahren Drangsalierung, Menschenverachtung und so weiter hinter der Showbühne mir gesagt habe, diesen Kulturbetrieb, schauen sie sich mal den WDR an, das geht ja einfach gar nicht und so. Diese Aufklärung kriegen wir jetzt von Marce Hilscher, was ich wirklich crazy finde, weil das die genuinen Aufgaben von Sendungen, wie der Kulturzeit sind, mir genau das zu liefern, mir genau diesen Kontrapunkt zu geben, statt eben noch mal das heutige Journal einfach zu verlängern mit Berichten, die da nur drei Minuten Zeit hatten und dann halt in der Kulturzeit sieben Minuten lang sein dürfen. Also es sind wirklich schlimme Zeiten, was jetzt nicht über Bande heißt, dass das Hotel Matze ein schlechter Podcast ist oder so, sondern Matze Hilscher macht halt einen Podcast, der eine Nische bespielt, von der ich aber jetzt sage, so langsam werden diese Nischen wirklich wichtiger als der Mainstream. Also wir sind hier auf haltlosen Gebiet. Und jetzt wird uns erklärt, dass dieser Mainstream nicht nur nicht gerettet, sondern geradezu aus Budgetgründen zerstört wird. Uns fehlt Geld, also was ist denn das bitte für eine Erklärung? Uns fehlt Geld und wenn uns Geld fehlt, dann uns fehlt kein Geld.
Auch die, die jetzt nach Erneuerung rufen, die machen mir fast noch mehr Angst als die, die die Streichung wollen. Da war bei redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland ein Artikel zu lesen und da hieß es, Dreisat habe zu lange am Götzen Theater festgehalten. Also man müsste doch den Kulturbegriff erweitern, denke ich, das wird doch sowieso die ganze Zeit getan und außerdem ist es auch nicht schlimm, wenn ein paar Mal im Monat mal eine Oper oder ein Theaterstück im Fernsehen gezeigt wird. Für all die Leute, die da sonst noch nie waren, ist das eine Gelegenheit und nicht jeder kann nach Salzburg reisen und guckt sich da eine Oper an. Also schaut man sich das dort an, was dort inszeniert wurde. Und ich habe schon große Sorge, wenn man jetzt einfach so ein Erneuerungsprogramm macht, dann wird das am Ende sowas sein wie First Books, moderiert von Sophie Passmann, sie unterhält sich mit Influencern, die zum ersten Mal in ihrem Leben ein Buch lesen, dazu spielt die Antilopen Gang und am Ende sagt irgendwas noch Ai-Wai-Wai und das war's. Also man kann sich auch schon große Sorgen machen, wie die Erneuerung aussieht. Aber gucken wir uns erst mal diese Zahlen an.
Die rundfunkkommission hat eine Gruppe von Fernsehkanälen in drei Körbe eingeordnet. Von den zehn genannten Kanälen sollen drei bis sechs künftig wegfallen. Im Bereich information geht es um Tagesschau 24, Phoenix, ARD Alpha und ZDF Info. Von den vier Kanälen sollen ein bis zwei übrig bleiben. Für Zuschauer zwischen drei und 45 Jahren sieht die kommission ebenfalls vier Kanäle. Kieker, Funk, ARD One und ZDF Neo. Zwei bis drei davon sollen bleiben. Zum Kulturbereich zählt die Politik Arte und Dreisat. Arte soll bleiben, die Inhalte von Dreisat teilweise oder vollständig in Arte überführt werden. Was heißt das für den Kulturbereich? Aus zwei mach eins? Geht das überhaupt? Dreisat ist ein gemeinsames Programm deutschsprachiger Sender aus Deutschland, Österreich und der Schweiz, dem federführenden ZDF, dem ORF, dem SRF und der ARD. Dreisat feiert in diesem Jahr 40-jähriges Jubiläum. Bei seiner Gründung überwand Dreisat die Grenzen Nachkriegs Europas. Bis heute ist es das einzige Gemeinschaftsprogramm im deutschen Sprachraum geblieben. Mit kulturellem Schwerpunkt, aber auch Bildung und Wissenschaft nehmen einen großen Raum ein. Arte ist eine deutsch-französische kooperation, die per Staatsvertrag gegründet wurde und 1992 auf den Sender ging. Heute hat Arte assoziationsverträge mit elf weiteren europäischen Sender.
Wir sehen, das sind zwei sehr europäische Projekte. Wenn einem etwas an Europa liegt, dann würde man genau diese beiden Sender stärken und würde sie nicht schwächen wollen. Das große Problem ist aber jetzt, wie Hans Zahmann vorgeht. Hier wurde jetzt alles nur reportiert. Dann kommt ein Herr vom Deutschen Kulturrat und sagt, angesichts des Rechtsradikalismus, der immer stärker wird, ist es wichtig, dass wir die Sender haben. Deswegen sind die so bedroht. Momentan entscheidet noch keine einzige AfD-Regierung über den Erhalt von Dreiseit oder Arte. Nein, das ist etwas, was man adressieren muss an CDU, SPD, Grüne, FDP. Die sind das Problem. Es wird ja gerade so getan, als sei die AfD jetzt der einzige Feind, den man ausmacht. Das ist, glaube ich, auch der Grund, warum diese ganze Kulturbranche so handzahm geworden ist. Man sieht immer nur die AfD als den Feind, und das ist er ja auch. Aber damit sind dann alle anderen, die nicht AfD sind, gleichzeitig der Freund. Ja, also da gibt es keine Reibung mehr, sondern alles ist in Ordnung. Und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich auch Arthur und Reiser nur deshalb erhalten, um etwas gegen die AfD zu tun. Und das ist mir ein bisschen zu wenig. Also wenn die Kunst- und die Kulturszene sich nur noch rechtfertiger kann darüber, dass damit der Faschismus aufgehalten wird, dann braucht man sie fast nicht mehr. Das ist wirklich so bitter zu sehen und dass auch da nicht mal, auch beim Sender, man längst überlegt, andere Wege zu gehen. Also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum gibt es nur so wenige eigenproduktionen. Man muss ja keine teuren Sendungen machen, sondern warum gibt es zum Beispiel nicht eine Kritiker-Runde nach Filmen, die gezeigt wurden. Das kann ja der große ARD-Film oder ZDF-Film sein, das kann aber auch der Film sein, den man dann gerade auf 3Sat gesehen hat. Warum gibt es danach nicht ein Format, in dem 40 Minuten lang Kritiker über den gesehenen Film diskutieren, den dann auch die ganzen Zuschauer gesehen haben. Das wäre ja ein interessantes Format. Kostenpunkt wahrscheinlich 500.000 Euro die gesamte Sendung, inklusive Licht und Kamera. Aber nein, es werden dann, wenn irgendwelche merkwürdigen Projekte realisiert, Leute werden durch die Welt geschickt mit 15 Kameras. Oder man kauft einfach Dokus ein, die zum Teil auch langweilig sind. Und dass man da nicht neue Wege gegangen ist, das finde ich bedenklich. Dass aber jetzt auch man sich nicht mit Vehemenz gegen diese Vorschläge stellt, sondern eigentlich nur mal so ganz brav den Finger hebt und sagt, also ja, mit der AfD, das wäre vielleicht doch gar nicht gut, wenn wir jetzt hier einen Sender verlieren. Wie erklärst du dir das, dass man so präsig eigentlich ist?
Das kann ich dir erklären. Zum einen wollen wir hier kurz in den Zeitgeist reinhören. Wir haben über Thüringen gesprochen. Und in Thüringen drohte ja die Staatskanzlei an die AfD zu fallen. Was heißt, dass die ganzen Vorschläge zum Thema, die KF macht ja erst mal nur finanzielle Vorschläge, die Sender reagieren da drauf und müssen sich das abnicken lassen in die großen Staatsverträge von den Ländern. Dort sind aber nicht die Ministerpräsidenten, sondern halt die Staatskanzlei-Chefs dafür verantwortlich. Was bedeutet, wenn die AfD fraktionsstärkste Partei ist, aber nicht den Ministerpräsidenten posten bestimmt, sondern was weiß ich, den Rest der Regierung oder sowas, dann kommt man da drum rum. Aber es gibt natürlich Zugkräfte. Wir hören hier kurz in dem Podcast von Ulf Poschart. Ulf Poschart ist, wie wir kennen, gern gesehen ist Porsche-Fahrer-Opfer auf Twitter. Jeder macht sich lustig über ihn, aber man kann ihn mir auch mal kurz zuhören. Er hat hier eine Idee. Wir hatten den NZZ-Artikel gelesen, wo drin stand, wieso reagiert die CDU nicht gemütlich mit der AfD? Die Mehrheit ist doch solide und so. Ulf Poschart hat einen Podcast mit dem Vorsaschef. Die verbinden also Ulf Poscharts radikale Ideen mit so ein paar demoskopischen Erhebungen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das, was wir jetzt hören, demoskopisch tragfähig ist, wenn man die Leute wirklich fragen würde. Aber Ulf Poschart formuliert es so.
Wenn ich jetzt ganz sarkastisch wäre, dann würde ich sagen, die realpolitische Forderung der AfD zu sagen, wenn wir einen Ministerpräsident stellen, dann treten wir aus dem Rundfunk-Staatsvertrag aus. Ich glaube, das war etwas, was sie garantieren wollen. Sagen wir mal so, das ist mal eine realpolitische Forderung, glaube ich, unter der könnte sich eine Mehrheit der Bundesbürger versammeln. Aber wie gesagt, die AfD ermöglicht diese Mehrheit nicht, sondern sie verhindert es eher, weil sie sich an so vielen Punkten einfach vollkommen indiskutabel äußert und damit jeden Weg versperrt, in der Mitte ein vernünftiger Gesprächspartner zu sein.
Also die AfD ist leider, laut Ul-Porsche, eine rechtsradikale Partei, die das auch immer zeigt, womit sie sich Spielräume nimmt, um ihre realpolitisch vernünftigen Vorschläge, die sicherlich eine Mehrheit in der Bevölkerung fänden, umzusetzen, wie zum Beispiel, wir schaffen den MDR ab.
Und das gesamte öffentlich-rechtliche Programm.
Genau. Wir wissen, er ist Weltchefredakteur, das ist Springer.
Ja.
So, jetzt können wir uns natürlich die Frage stellen, wie viel Geld brauchen die denn bei Dreisat? Wäre das nicht mal ein Mit-Zähnen-Projekt? Könnte nicht einer der 249 Milliardäre 0,1% seines Vermögens dafür aufwenden, die Rendite daraus zu verwenden, um Dreisat zu retten? Wir wissen, die Milliardäre entscheiden anders. Also hinter Julian Reichelt steht ein Milliardär.
Mit der Aufspaltung geht der Plan auf.
Hinter Julian Reichelt steht ein Milliardär. Und an der Spitze von Springer steht auch ein Milliardär. So, während also Julian Reichelt, also Bild 2.0, gerade neun Milliardär gefunden hat, um einfach das Blatt auf Linie zu kriegen, wird Bild und Welt jetzt auch auf Linie gebracht. Wir hören hier Börsenberichte ARD.
Mit der Aufspaltung geht der Plan auf, der vor fünf Jahren...
Also der Aufspaltung von Springer. Es gibt Bild, Welt, die publizistische Einheit und dann diesen ganzen, wofür sich die amerikanischen Investoren interessieren.
Das übernimmt dann KKR.
Genau, das macht dann KKR....
des US-Finanzinvestors begann, den Unternehmenswert steigern, Springer neu strukturieren und damit gewinnen machen. Tatsächlich ist der Springer-Konzern heute doppelt so viel wert wie damals. Matthias Döpfner steigt endgültig zu einer Art Alleinherrscher bei den Springer-Medien auf mit nahezu unkontrollierter Macht.
Also diese erfolgreichen, sag ich mal medialen produktion, die im Sinne von Steffen Maus Aufklärung die Arenen ordentlich organisieren und bespielen und die im Sinne wurden, wir werden es heute von Taylor Lawrence lesen, die die Washington Post jetzt verlässt, um independent ihr Kulturprojekt Kulturjournalismus zu fahren. Also wir haben eine Bespielung der Öffentlichkeit, eine ganz instrumentelle und perverse Bespielung der Öffentlichkeit von Milliardären, die entweder diese Läden übernehmen oder neu gründen. Aber wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ihre...
Und die Kunst und Kultur spielt da keine Rolle. Also ich meine, man kann das bei der Welt, die machen noch ein bisschen Kultur, aber das ist ja lachhaft darüber zu sprechen.
Absolut.
Und deswegen wäre jetzt natürlich an der Zeit, dass man sich auf die Hochkultur besinnt. Wir versuchen das ja hier im Salon immer wieder zu tun. Wir blicken aber jetzt noch über diese eine Kürzungsdebatte hinaus auf eine andere, nämlich eine, die in Berlin tobt. Dazu dann auch ein Kulturzeitbeitrag.
Auch Berlin muss sparen. Nun geht's an die Kultur. Berlins Kulturetat soll 2025 und 2026 mit etwa 150 millionen Euro weniger auskommen. Von einem Kahlschlag.
Wir machen immer gerade stopp 150 millionen Euro. Das ist nix. Das könnte man jetzt gerade mal so irgendwo einsammeln gehen, wenn man beim Borchardt sitzt. Dann könnte man einfach sagen, gibt doch mal 150 millionen. Wir brauchen die hier. Das Jahresbudget von Berlin liegt bei 40 Milliarden. Und von diesen 40 Milliarden, da sagt man jetzt ja, da müsste man doch ein bisschen Sparsamkeit walten lassen. Also wo könnte man da ran? Natürlich bei der Kultur 150 millionen Euro.
Du musst jetzt 0,2 Promille des Etats auf 0,17 drücken oder so. Das ist die wichtigste Aufgabe der Politik gerade.
Ja, ich frage mich überhaupt bei diesen ganzen Debatten, wo ist Claudia Roth? Also wäre das jetzt nicht so eine Sache, wo sie sich mal äußern kann? Ich meine, vielleicht sollen wir dankbar sein, dass sie sich nicht geäußert hat. Wenn immer sie sich äußert, dann geht es ja genau daneben. Insofern, ja, schön, am besten fliegt Claudia Roth bis zum Ende der legislaturperiode in den Urlaub, dann kann sie schon mal von dort nichts mehr anrichten. Wir hören mal weiter.
Für die Kultur in Berlin spricht die Kulturszene in einem offenen Brief, den sie an Berlins Senat richtet. Dieser Brief ist jetzt auch Gegenstand einer online-petition mit inzwischen fast 40.000 Unterstützern. Wir haben nachgefragt und beginnen an der Staatsoper Berlin. Hier sucht die klassische Musikszene Berlin ihresgleichen und ist von weltweiter Bedeutung.
Wenn das wirklich so gemacht wird.
Wir hören jetzt Christian Thielemann.
Es ist eine Katastrophe, weil so viel Geld hier bereits gebunden ist und das, was man einsparen kann, ist effektiv das, was die Zuschauer sehen und hören. Gerade Berlin ist ja in den letzten Jahren berühmt dadurch, was man hier alles machen kann. Also vom Feiern bis zum Club, vom Off-Theater bis zum wunderschönen gelackten Opernhaus. Sie können hier alles haben und das muss erhalten bleiben. Die Vielfalt ist es. Und da können sie nicht einfach was wegnehmen und sagen, du hast sowieso so viel, dann nehmen wir was weg. Dann geht die Vielfalt flöten.
Es ist ganz klar auch ein Verlust von Arbeitsplätzen. Ein großer Verlust von Arbeitsplätzen. Bei uns sind Personalkosten 80 Prozent, fünf Prozent fixe Kosten wie Strom, Heizung, Licht, all das. Und nur 15 Prozent können wir wirklich einsetzen für den tagtäglichen Kunst, für das tagtägliche Kunsterlebnis.
80 Prozent Personalkosten, sagt die Intendantin der Oper. Das heißt, es kann nur dort gekürzt werden. Also es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass man sagt, na dann macht man die Kulissen nicht so aufwendig, sondern es kann nur bedeuten weniger Leute. Kleineres Orchester, kleineres Ensemble, günstigere Sänger, die mit Gastengagement kommen.
Wir haben hier voll Elan und Freude und Begeisterung angefangen und stehen jetzt eigentlich wirklich vollkommen erschrocken vor dieser Androhung, sage ich. Und ja, ich hoffe wahnsinnig, dass es nicht dazu kommt.
Auch an der Schaubühne Berlin ist die Stimmung gedämpft. Kultur sei das Herz von Berlin und zieht Menschen aus aller Welt an. Sagt Thomas Ostermeyer von der Schaubühne Berlin.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass Berlin ein Pfund hat in der Kultur, mit dem es wuchern muss. Und wenn es eine Richtlinienpolitik geben sollte des regierenden Bürgermeisters, sollte er nicht nur Sicherheit, Justiz, Bildung, Wissenschaft und Forschung ausnehmen von den Kürzungen, sondern für die Stadt auch die Kultur, weil sie so einen geringen Anteil am Landeshaushalt hat und weil sie so stark strahlt und ein Teil der faszination und der Attraktivität dieser Stadt ausmacht.
Klassische Instituts, das ist auch interessant, das argumentieren auch alle immer nur noch in Bezug auf, was hilft der Stadt. Also es gibt gar nicht mehr eine diskussion über den Selbstzweck von Kunst, sondern es ist nur noch instrumentell, ja, wir bringen doch Leute hier hin oder sowas. Also ich meine, das stimmt, diese argumentation ist richtig und man muss sie vielleicht auch machen, weil eine andere gar nicht mehr bei diesen Leuten in der Politik verfängt. Aber es ist auch traurig. Auch hier nochmal jetzt Staatsballett Berlin, da geht es auch wieder ums Personal.
aktionen wie das Staatsballett Berlin sehen wichtige kreative kooperationen in Gefahr, sagt Intendant Christian Spuck.
Wir haben mit den berühmtesten Choreografen und Künstlern Verträge abgeschlossen, sind in Gesprächen und wenn wir die jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr bezahlen können und uns von denen trennen müssten, das wäre eine ziemliche Katastrophe. Die Frage ist natürlich dann auch, was spielen wir denn dann? Wenn wir dann nur Repertoire spielen, Giselle und Schwansee, das erschöpft sich irgendwann, das Publikum wird dann nicht mehr kommen. Das heißt, wir haben keine Einnahmen mehr und dann müssen wir, und das ist der absolute Albtraum, müssen wir an die Struktur ran. Das heißt, wir müssen Arbeitsplätze einsparen und die Company verkleinern, damit wir überhaupt noch was zeigen können.
Ja, also Gutes Geld verweist ja auf einen neuen Maßstab neben BIP, einen Nutzwert wirtschaftlicher Tätigkeiten, sag ich mal. Und zum anderen auf so einen impressionismus, den sie ja mitbringt, dass sie sagt, ich kam da im deutschen Finanzministerium an, nachdem ich in Liberia gearbeitet habe, und hab plötzlich festgestellt, ah ja, hier bin ich in einem Land, hier gibt's Knete. Was man schon daran sieht. Nicht nur ist das Finanzministerium ein Protzbau, sondern auch die Straßenzüge drumrum. Und die einzigen diskussionen, die dort geführt werden, sind die libarianischen, wo können wir hier nochmal was kürzen, wo können wir nochmal was sparen. Und sie fragt sich so, warum? Warum, warum, warum, warum? Also darum geht's heute im Salon.
Warum? Ja, es sieht düster aus. Und ich glaube, dass man auch von der Berliner Kulturszene aus sehr viel vehementer gegen die Politik vorgehen sollte. Also nicht nur so instrumentelle argumentationen liefern, sondern einfach mal mehr auf konfrontation setzen, darüber mal einen Druck herstellen. Vielleicht hat man sich auch zu lange zu anschmiegsam verhalten, wollte am Ende doch jeden Abend im Schloss Bellevue denieren und hat sich deshalb immer brav verhalten. Und dann ist man aber irgendwann nicht mehr das geliebte Kind und wird einfach aussortiert. Wäre man vielleicht von Anfang an konfrontativer unterwegs, würde man mit einer lauten Stimme und nicht mit so einer zögerlichen, zarten Stimme sprechen, dann wäre die Kultur auch viel präsenter im Raum.
Und interessanter.
Und interessanter, ja. Denn das ist ja wirklich, man kriegt ja viel vorgestellt, was es so alles zu sehen und zu hören gibt. Und wenn ich auch an diese Kulturzeitberichterstattung denke, das meiste ist auch einfach wahnsinnig langweilig, genau weil es so angepasst ist. Und ich brauche nicht 57 Theaterstücke zum Thema Fake News. Ich weiß, was Fake News sind. Vielleicht doch mal lieber ein gutes Streifwerkett.
Ich habe Faust hier in Frankfurt verpasst. Ich war so abgeneigt vom Schauspieler, dass ich mir gar nicht das Programm angeschaut habe. Da habe ich gesehen, es hat achtmal gespielt, alles ausverkauft.
Gut.
Das ist schlecht.
Wir machen jedenfalls, ja wer weiß, vielleicht hast du Glück gehabt.
Na ja, Sachen, die man in der Schule selbst gespielt hat, wollen wir ja auch nochmal von Profis nehmen, weißt du?
Ja, wir gehen irgendwann mal eine Faust. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal zum Salon über und nachdem, wie das Kulturfernsehen jetzt so weiter zusammengestrichen wird, also wir machen das Kulturfernsehen weiter. Das ist dann hinter der Paywall, ist aber günstiger als der Rundfunkbeitrag. Wir werden nämlich nicht nur über das Buch Gutes Geld von Philippa Siegel Klöckner sprechen, sondern ich werde auch noch Musik empfehlen. Wir machen eine Winterreise.
Das ist auch schon kalt.
Ich verspreche da Großartiges. Dann gibt es einen Roman, der ist in Versform verfasst.
Sehr gut, ich sage dir.
Über den Weltuntergang.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und der ist vielleicht...
Kriegst du was vor?
Erträglich, wenn er so poetisch ist. Ich trage, versuche auch etwas vorzutragen, ja. Dann hast du dir ja gewünscht, dass wir mal über den Gegenstandpunkt sprechen. Ich habe auch einige Beiträge darin gelesen und bin sehr gespannt, wie gut es dir gefallen hat.
Ich habe alle absolviert. Ich habe ein E-Pub geschickt bekommen, nachdem ich es kaufte. Habe das in meine Ich lese dir alles vor App geladen. Die hat gesagt, eine Stunde neunzehn. Also habe ich gesagt, okay. Also ich habe sozusagen den ganzen Gegenstandpunkt absolviert.
Aber das ist auch in einem Duktus geschrieben, bei dem man so die Ironie dann nicht raushört, oder? Wenn man es nicht selbst. Also so eine Stimme liest das doch neutral vor. Aber da sind ja Abschnitte drin, die doch, sagen wir, ironisch bis sarkastisch sind.
Ich habe ja jetzt den Gegenstand absolviert. Ich kann mich den Gegenstandpunkt, ich kann mich also nur noch erinnern, was ich vorher dachte, was das ist, nachdem junge Leute bei uns im Büro meinten, das lesen irgendwie alle und so, keine Ahnung. Deswegen möchte ich gerne noch ein bisschen an der Romantik festhalten, der Gegenstandpunkt hat keine Autornamen, sondern man zieht sich zurück auf Argument und Analyse und serviert ein Gemeinschaftsprodukt. Und in meinem Kopf hatte ich das genauso, auch die rezeptionsgeschichte. Junge Menschen treffen sich und lesen sich das gegenseitig vor. Also wenn du mir jetzt sagst, den Gegenstandpunkt nur zu hören, sei aber nicht ganz adäquat, da würde ich sagen, nein, das entspricht auch genau der Romantik, dass einem das jemand vorträgt. Dass man nicht nur den Text, die Analyse und die Argumente, sondern auch noch Stimme und Stimmung hat.
Aber die kommen glaube ich alle aus dem Fränkischen, da müsste man es auf Fränkisch vorlesen.
Meine helfen kannst du ja jeden einstellen. Also die liest dir das auf Fränkisch vor.
Also wir lesen nachher den Gegenstandpunkt auf Fränkisch. Außerdem habe ich eine Studie gelesen zum Thema Degrowth-Studien und diese Meta-Studie besagt, mit Empirie ist da aber wenig los. Es ist ganz erschreckend zu lesen. Und wir blicken noch auf ein geopolitisches Tarant, nämlich die Arktis. Dort hat sich seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine auch manches verändert.
Ich lese Nexus von Harari, bin enttäuscht, sage aber auch warum. Gegenstandpunkt wie angemerkt, außerdem gab es in der Zeitung kommunikation und Recht einen Beitrag zu einer sehr wichtigen, aber unbeobachteten, also von Fachleuten schon, deswegen heute mal Special Interest. Der BGH hat entschieden, dass das Patentamts- oder das Patentgericht Recht hatte, KI's können keine Erfinder sein. Du hast ja schon gesagt, sie können keine Künstler sein. Also die können durchaus Werke schaffen und Inhalte generieren, aber wir wollen sie mal nicht auf sozialen Range oder Augenhöhe lassen. Und Taylor Lawrence verlässt die Washington Post und sagt, sie macht jetzt independent. Und wir haben ihr Buch gelesen, Extremely Online, fand das auch sehr gut. Und sie stellt da Prinzipien vor, von denen ich sage, das ist nicht nur Internetkultur, sondern das ist jetzt Journalismus in Anführungszeichen allgemein. Ganz selten sieht man ja jemanden, der die kleinen Änderungen in der Welt aufgreift, das ernst nimmt und danach handelt und wir alle fragen uns, was hat es mit diesem Chaos auf sich? Warum fehlt da plötzlich Geld? Macht das alles überhaupt Sinn? Und man kann ja durchaus mal rangehen und sagen, Chaos ist jetzt normal, macht das Sinn? Nein, es macht keinen Sinn. Kann man es beobachten? Ja klar, kann man es beobachten. Man muss halt einfach nur mal sich darüber verständigen, wie man das jetzt beobachtet. Und dann einfach das nächste Heute schon allzu machen. Mal gucken, wer heute moderiert. So und deswegen denke ich mir, ihr kleiner Aufschlag, Begründungen, warum sie jetzt independent geht, den kann man mal allgemein beherzigen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf und da auch nochmal die Empfehlungen. Wir haben über Taylor Lawrence Buch Extremly Online ausführlich im Salon gesprochen. Man erfährt wirklich Erstaunliches über Instagram zum Beispiel, welche Rolle die Mütter spielten, um diese Plattform groß zu machen. Wir haben dann auch die Mami Blogger und sie geht da ganz tief rein und beobachtet und beobachtet. Und wir können dann unsere Schlussfolgerungen selbst daraus ziehen, unsere Ableitungen vornehmen. Wer diesen Podcast unterstützen will und auch Lust hat auf gute Bücher, viele Empfehlungen und eine diskussion, bei der ich gespannt bin, wohin sie uns heute führt, bei Gutes Geld, kann uns abonnieren.
Und zwar muss uns abonnieren. Man kann uns nicht hören ohne Abonnement.
Richtig. Und zwar geht das über Steady ganz einfach auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Button. Ab drei Euro kann man dann diesen Salon abonnieren und kann auch alle alten Salons, das gesamte Archiv von Januar 2020 anhören. Wer es bequemer möchte über Apple, dort schon seine Accounts hat, kann auch dort den Salon abonnieren. Dort ist er ein bisschen teurer, weil Apple ja immer noch eine extra Gebühr verlangt. Aber dieser praktische Weg steht auch offen. Und wer schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, kann dann über Patreon den Salon auch abonnieren. Jetzt musst du noch ganz kurz sagen, weil manche immer noch nicht so sich fragen, ist das denn was für mich, wenn man nicht so technikaffin ist? Ich habe einen Autor in Berlin getroffen, der hatte das abgeschlossen und wusste dann nicht so recht, das zu öffnen. Er war ein bisschen überfordert. Er ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig digital affin. Aber eigentlich ist es ganz leicht und wir bekommen so gut wie nie irgendeine Rückmeldung, dass etwas nicht funktioniert. Das heißt, man kann, so wie man immer Podcast hört, auch weiterhin Podcast hören, wenn man es abschließt.
In seiner Lieblings-App, also meine definition von Podcast, und wir haben jetzt im Oktober wieder die Subscribe, kommt alle, ist, dass man einen Podcast hört, wie man einen Podcast nun mal hört. Man abonniert ihn. Das ist erstmal grundsätzlich kostenfrei. Manchmal hat es eine Paywall wie bei uns. Man hat also eine App auf seinem Handy, die ist auch schon vorinstalliert, wenn man Android oder Apple benutzt. Man kann aber noch viele andere runterladen, die denselben Zweck erfüllen und manchmal ein paar funktionalitäten haben, in der man darauf hingewiesen wird, wenn der neue Podcast da ist. Man wacht morgens auf und dann steht auf dem Handy, neuer Salon besprochen wird, bla bla bla, Bild, möchtest du den hören? Dann drückt man auf Play und dann geht's los. Einfacher geht es nicht. Wir vertreiben ihn natürlich bei Steady auf einer Webseite, die hat auch einen Player. Also man kann sich da anmelden, bezahlen und dann sieht man einen Player auf einer Webseite. Nur ein Player auf einer Webseite, so hört man keinen Podcast. Also das macht man grundsätzlich nicht.
Ich mache sowas natürlich hier noch nie.
Ja, es gibt noch die Orchideen, aber eigentlich hat man dafür eine App auf seinem Smartphone. Also eigentlich hat man ein Smartphone und darauf eine App.
Weißt du, dass ich mir manchmal Podcast runter lade auf einen USB-Stick und diesen dann ins Auto stecke?
Ja gut, wenn der USB-Stick das einzige, ich lade hier was auf meinem autoradio ist, dann ist das ja auch alles genehm. Nur der moderne Mensch und der Podcast ist eigentlich Traumhochzeit. Das funktioniert ganz wunderbar. Man bekommt es einfach geliefert, man drückt auf Play, fertig. Wenn man jährlich bezahlt, kriegt man das auch ein ganzes Jahr lang, ohne darüber nachdenken zu müssen. Das ist sozusagen das Ziel und es ist sehr einfach zu erreichen. Also für Leute, die jetzt überzeugt sind, okay, ich abonniert den Salon. Das ist das Ziel und das schafft man innerhalb von drei Minuten, sich so einzurichten.
Es geht übrigens auch über Spotify. Dann wird man direkt von Spotify auf Steady gelenkt und kann dann dort in Abord schließen.
Spotify, Apple Podcasts, Google Podcasts. Man kann uns in jeder Podcast App hören. Es ist super easy und Steady hilft einem auch weiter, wenn man technische Probleme hat. Wenn ihr uns schreibt, sagen wir Steady hilft euch weiter. Und dann hören wir nie wieder davon, weil Steady dann weitergeholfen hat.
Also da kommt aber in der Regel gar nicht vor.
Es ist nicht sehr kompliziert. Außerdem will ich darauf hinweisen, unser allererstes Buch, das wir gelesen hatten, war im Oktober 2020 Bullshit Jobs.
Das war nicht unser allererstes Buch. Das erste Buch, das wir gemeinsam gesprochen haben.
Das heißt, wir nähern uns auch dem 50. gemeinsam besprochenen Buch. Es ist dann, nehme ich mal an, 50 Monate später, also das Dezember-Buch dieses Jahres. Plus natürlich noch mal und mehr Bücher, du bringst da vor allem immer Bücher mit. Also wir haben hier solide Datengrundlage für moderne Gehirne.
Gut, dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.